oh hello are you tired of going through
old gift cards you got lying around and
wondering if there's any money still
left on them why go all the way to the
store to find out when you can just send
your gift cards to me ed Pinsky these
just came in today let's test them with
my highly sophisticated gift card
testing machine this one's got nothing
on it oh well nothing on that one either
but I bet your gift cards are worth lots
of money so send them to me head was
there any money on the clothing and
jewelry store gift cards I sent you nope
nothing on those better luck next time
how about that department store gift
card I sent you nothing there either pal
keep sending those cards hey Penske I
sent you three cards last week and I
still haven't heard back I understand
your concern but don't worry you can
trust me I better hear from you soon or
I'm calling the police go ahead I'm
retired now anyway you son of a [ __ ]
done by the guy
known as it rockin drive
[Music]
[Applause]